[Music]
rebecca's in jacksonville florida hi
rebecca how are you
well hello mr dave ramsey
i oh my gosh i can't believe i'm talking
to you
okay
pull myself together it's all right
rebecca breathe there you go
you got through kiddo you got through
okay how can we help yes sir
well um so i have a bit of a fun story i
guess um
i my husband and i uh we're 26 years old
we have two children two beautiful girls
and whenever my husband got out of high
school he bought this house that we're
living in and
it's right across the street from my
mother-in-law um so
you know things were okay but this
beginning of the past past year
um
my father-in-law
he um he got really sick and
no one knew about it until day four
when uh my mother-in-law called and said
hey um you know larry's not doing really
well and so my husband went over and
checked on him and uh lo and behold he
was really really sick he was dehydrated
and he was he was not given any like
nutrition for four days
she was just giving him like ibuprofen
she didn't really know what to do i
would say
i was trying to give her the benefit of
the doubt but um whenever my husband
walked into the house it was like
extreme hoarder
um addition no air flow to the room and
all that kind of stuff so he went to the
hospital and i just said you know what
and i put my mama pants on and i said
she's not allowed to take care of him
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this and i knew
that he couldn't go back to the house
and my husband and i we just looked at
each other and we said this is why we
have an emergency fund because it's an
emergency and we don't want him to pass
away he was he's 82.
um so
four or five days later after the er the
doctors are like hey he's not doing well
say goodbye and we're like no no no so
we took him home we gave him sunshine he
had coveted and everything gave him
sunshine gave him you know just just
pursued god's you know
what what god told us to do with our
bodies and just try to pump him with
vitamins and everything and he got
better like uh the rebecca that's better
we're going to run out of time honey
how can we help you
how can we help you
um we have an opportunity to buy a house
that's quite it's worth more than what
she's asking but it's a fixer-upper um
so um
i know
so i'm just i'm sick and tired of being
so close to my mother-in-law and my
father-in-law and it's not sick and
tired it's just like i just don't you
moved your father-in-law in with you
he we did and also we got him back
that's the definition of living close to
him
yes sir
did you send me back
we did we sent him back after he got
well
so he's back down at the harder house
now
yeah and it was by choice and we try to
we really tried to just like
change everything but you can't change
it okay so you're you're not responsible
for what happens across the street
you're responsible for what happens in
your house so they're not bothering you
we figured that out no they're not
bothering you so why do you need to move
that's good question um it's just i
guess the whole
it's just
you know whenever they pass when when
she passes by it's always
a stop and kind of
embarrassing like yelling or
or uh demanding like to see her
grandchildren and and it it could be
more casual or it could be more like
you know set times but there's no
boundary lines i guess and we have to
constantly put them in place
and like um so she's like standing in
the street yelling at your house
sometimes yeah yeah and it's um it's not
it's not always that bad but it's just
for me i guess how old is she
um uh 63 and he's 80
um
so what does your husband what does your
husband say
he he he tries it's his mom so i know
what does he say about moving
oh he wants to do it we found an awesome
deal and we just don't know if we should
sell our house why not
move okay
okay
i mean i got a crazy woman standing in
the street yelling at my house yeah i'd
have a son in the yard looking for i
mean even if i'm not ken to her i'm
looking for a new place
that's a true especially if i'm ken yeah
it's like doubles the move yeah
rebecca yes i don't know what you're
afraid of wow make a good financial
decision but yeah it's good for your
family i mean you guys
there's a lot going on here that we
don't have dr john here to help us with
so
um yeah there's boundary issues there's
all kinds of stuff there's strange
strange hoarders and yeah if it happened
to the old guy once it's probably going
to happen again yeah it's like yeah but
you can still move him into the house at
the country too and then she'll be by
herself standing in the street yelling
at herself i guess i don't know
yeah i'm moving yes
as long as you can afford to make the
moves and i don't use this as an excuse
to do something financially stupid but
if you've got a lateral move or a move
you can afford to make let's go ahead
and make it